ashok ont la cote
mille merci mesdames messieurs
monsieur le préfet du parlement européen
mesdames messieurs les députés
je vous remercie de votre présence est
pour moi un grand honneur de me
retrouver parmi vous j'aurais aimé que
mon mari reçoivent ce prix lui même mais
je voudrais je voudrais si vous me
permettez vous demander de respecter une
minute de silence en hommage à la
mémoire de ceux qui sont tombés en
france et ailleurs
c'est le plus grand souhait de mon mari
une minute de silence en hommage aux
victimes
al chocolat quand je vous remercie
infiniment monsieur le président du
parlement européen
mesdames et messieurs les députés je
suis devant vous je vous parle de façon
ferme à vous les représentants de la
grande nation européenne pour vous dire
que je suis fier de représenter mon mari
est de me retrouver dans cette enceinte
une des plus grands anciens de la
démocratie dans le monde
mesdames messieurs si vous permettez je
souhaiterais commencé par une citation
d'un article écrit par mon mari
la liberté d'expression c'est comme
l'air que nous respirons que respirent
tout penseur c'est le combustible qui
nous fait penser et travailler et de
parlent les époques les nations se sont
cons progressé grâce à leurs consoeurs à
leurs idées à leur philosophie c'est
ainsi que les sociétés ont choisi leur
mode de pensée
ce qui les amène vers le progrès vers la
civilisation et la prospérité
les la communauté internationale et les
associations de juristes du monde entier
demandent aux régimes arabes de se
réformer de permettre la liberté
d'expression car elle pense que la
liberté d'expression est un droit
fondamental vous êtes un homme un être
humain donc vous avez le droit de penser
comme vous voulez vous pouvez croire
vous pouvez réfléchir vous pouvez aimer
vous pouvez détestez vous pouvez être
libéral ou islamistes le penseur
l'intellectuel arabe
s'il est un libre penseur
il a toujours fait des contorsions il a
tourné autour du pot afin de pouvoir de
façon subreptice faire passer son
message
car dans nos pays une pensée libre et
éclairé est considéré comme du blasphème
c'est l'idéologie de la ccit de
certaines sociétés arabes
les sociétés rap considère souvent que
une pensée libre est un relâchement une
décadence un éloignement du droit chemin
et de la religion est ce naturel bien
évidemment que non le penseur arabe et
la société d du monde arabe fonctions de
façon très peu naturelle un penseur doit
pouvoir s'exprimer librement
même si ses pensées peuvent être
erronées ou si le penseur pour cela doit
nager contre courant contre la pensée
religieuse
la société doit aussi être ouverte
accepter toutes sortes de pensées de
courants de pensée la société doit
pouvoir écouter l'opinion de l'autre de
la critique et de façon constructive et
ceci sur la base d'une d'un dialogue
constructif afin justement de faire
s'élever la pensée quelqu'un qui observe
la situation du monde arabe verra que la
société vit sous le joug d'un régime
théocratique un régime qui ne demandent
aux gens que d'être des béni oui oui je
vous parle des hommes de religion
ces sociétés sont imposés cette
soumission aux religieux aujourd'hui les
religieux font une course à celui qui
proposera la meilleure fatwa par exemple
exerçant ainsi une menace contre les
intellectuels qui essaye justement de
défendre leur libre pensée je crains
qu'il y ait un exode des cerveaux arabe
des penseurs éclairés qui iront chercher
un air plus frais ailleurs mesdames
messieurs mon mari avant d'être mis en
prison avait dit que les religieux et
said intimider les penseurs parce que
les penseurs risque un jour de leur
couper l'herbe sur sous les pieds et à
dévoiler leur ignorance et leurs
mensonges life badaoui est un jeune
saoudien qui est en prison qui croupit
en prison depuis 2012
il a été accusé de d'apostasié et il a
été condamné d'abord à la peine capitale
est ensuite à une peine très dure dix
ans de prison
trois cent mille dollars d'amande et
recevoir 1000 mesdames messieurs mille
coups de fouets qu'il recevra toutes les
semaines à raison de 50 coups de fouet
tous les vendredis après la prière
en plus d'une interdiction de voyager et
de faire des déclarations aux organes de
presse pendant dix ans encore après sa
mise en liberté après donc sa peine raif
n'est pas un criminel n'est pas un
violeur à ifs est un libre penseur un
esprit libre
quel est son crime tout simplement que
c'est une voie libre dans le pays de la
pensée unique
mon mari n'a pas été un criminel n'a pas
été un bandit de grand chemin n'a pas
été un trafiquant de drogue pour qu ils
méritent cette peine si dur ces coups de
fouet
mon mari s'est contentée d'exprimer sa
pensée de la coucher sur du papier tout
simplement mon mari rêve d'un monde
meilleur un monde qui acceptent la
pensée de l'autre dans le pays de la
pensée unique
il a parlé d'une voix très clair et
c'est ça qui les a dérangés mais ils en
ont fait une icône de la liberté non
seulement en arabie saoudite mais dans
le monde entier
rail badaoui est tout simplement un
penseur pacifique
il n'a pas voulu rester dans le coup
troupeau qui suit ces hommes de religion
qui vivent dans une autre époque et qui
appliquent leur loi dure mon mari a
parlé fort il s'est opposé à la barbarie
et à l'autoritarisme des religieux qui
ont répondu en frappant son frêle corps
de 50 coups de fouet
50 coups de fouet qui ont suscité les
réactions dans le monde entier des
réactions que nous voyons encore
aujourd'hui en corée en australie au
canada dans tous les pays tous les gens
se lèvent pour dire nous sommes reis ce
prix qui lui est accordée aujourd'hui
est un moment historique c'est aussi une
marque de courage à mettre sur votre
crédit monsieur le président c'est le
15e prix que reçoit mon mari en moins
d'un an
aujourd'hui il est le premier citoyen du
golfe arabe à recevoir le prix sakharov
mesdames messieurs je souhaiterais vous
remercier de m'avoir donné cette
occasion et cet honneur
je souhaiterais terminé en citant les
mots de mon mari à ceux qui nous veulent
la mort nous souhaitons la vie à ceux
qui veulent que nous restions ignorants
nous leur souhaitons de revenir à la
raison
je vous remercie de votre aimable
attention
petit
cette forge
libre chers collègues
mesdames et messieurs je crois qu en
votre nom à vous tous je puis